- Welcome, everyone,
and thank you for attending
the final panel of the conference,
"Political Lotteries:
The Future of Democracy."
So we decided to end the
conference with this panel
that allows us and the audience
to have a group brainstorm
about some of the benefits
and the challenges of using lotteries,
and also to tackle some bigger questions.
So should we get rid of elections?
Can deliberative institutions scale up?
What should new areas of
research and collaboration be?
This is also going to be the
chance for you, the audience,
to ask questions and
engage with the presenters.
And feel free to ask as many
questions as you'd like,
and there will be individuals
around to pass you a mic.
So once we begin to open Q&A,
please look to Kira in
the back for a microphone.
So we'll begin with a half
hour of prepared questions
and then open it up.
But, first, I'm very pleased
to introduce your panelists.
So on the far side, Federica Carugati
is a Senior Lecturer in
History and Political Economy
at King's College London.
Her research, as you've seen
earlier in the conference,
focuses on two topics:
the development of political, legal,
and economic institutions
and pre-modern
citizens-centered governments,
and second, the lessons that
the emergence, configuration,
and breakdown of such institutions hold
for the theory and practice
of institution building
in the modern world.
She's the author of two books,
"A Moral Political Economy:
Present, Past, and Future,"
that's Cambridge University Press,
and "Creating a Constitution:
Law, Democracy, and
Growth in Ancient Athens,"
from Princeton University Press,
as well as a number of articles
published in academic and popular outlets,
including an article I love in WIRED.
Next to her is Dmitri Landa,
who's a Professor of Politics at NYU.
His research focuses on democratic theory,
formal theory, and political economy,
as well as philosophy and law.
His recent research has focused on
studying deliberation and debate,
including experimental and formal work
as to what extent the debate process
is informative to participants,
as well as research on how to structure
deliberative activities of argumentation,
information acquisition, and learning.
Most relatedly, he's
working on a book manuscript
with Ryan Pevnick, also at NYU, entitled,
"Representative Democracy:
A Justification,"
with Oxford University Press.
And this manuscript compares
the electoral selection
of policymaking officials
to salient alternatives,
many of which we've talked about today,
such as direct democracy,
lottery-based systems,
and lottocratic alternatives.
Next to Dmitri is Philip Lindsay,
who leads the Democracy Innovation Hub
at The Hannah Arendt Center
for Politics and
Humanities at Bard College.
Since 2022, the hub has
hosted two annual convenings
on citizens' assemblies
that bring together elected officials,
community leaders,
advocates, and practitioners
to workshop precisely how to
scale collaborative governance
from a place-based perspective.
The hub also recently hosted
the "Doing Democracy
Differently" teacher fellowship,
which trains high school teachers
on how to bring deliberative
democracy into the classroom.
He's co-founder of the Assembly Project,
as we've heard about earlier,
and helps coordinate the
Energized New York initiative.
And last but not least, Kris.
Kris Rose is the head of
Governance Insights at Meta,
where he works across the company
to drive thought on emerging trends
at the intersection of technology,
society, and governance.
Prior to this role,
Kris helped launch the
company's Oversight Board,
as well as serving as
a geopolitical analyst
at the CIA for a decade
to include secondment as the
president's daily briefer
to then US President Mike Pence,
and most recently served
as the senior advisor
at the Cybersecurity and
Infrastructure Security Agency
during the Biden administration.
Kris holds a master in public
policy from Georgetown,
and is a team member also
with the Council on Foreign Relations.
So as you see, we brought together
a combination of academics,
practitioners, and folks from industry
to tackle these big questions.
Now, I've given each of the panelists
the opportunity to have opening statements
to tell you, the audience,
about their current research
or their current activities.
And we'll start in the
order that I introduced you,
so Federica, please.
- Okay. Is this good? Okay.
So, yeah, Ali asked for us to give
a little bit of a brief,
I guess, on the research.
Again, I don't wanna bore you too much,
given that some of you at least
have been in the audience long enough
to know pretty much what
my research is about,
but just for the sake of
the recording, I suppose,
I am trained as a historian,
by ambition, a political scientist,
and I study pre-modern governance,
particularly pre-modern democratic
or collective governance.
And after spending a,
someone might say, too much time
thinking about governance
in Ancient Athens,
I decided to broaden the
scope of the investigation
to studying instances
of collective governance
in the pre-modern world
that go beyond Athens,
that go beyond in most recently Europe,
with the hope that broadening the scope
of the investigation on
historical collective governance
might give us better, more robust insights
about what collective governance
might look like today.
And so the idea is not
so much to sort of like
lose myself in historical experiments
or historical evidence,
but it is to bring that evidence
to conversations about building
democratic spaces today,
particularly at a time when democracy
seems to be not as cool an experiment
as we thought maybe a
couple of decades ago,
or even less than that.
So, again, I think that just to be
relatively brief and clear,
I think that there is a lot to learn
about historical collective governance
for building a theory,
a more robust theory of
collective governance today,
but also to really provide additional
sort of like a food for thoughts
for all those communities,
many of which we have discussed today.
They are trying to build
collective governance spaces
online and offline.
And I think that this is what
my research is trying to do.
Although it is somehow and
often, perhaps too often,
dorking out on things historical,
it is pretty much inspired
by a focus on practice
and a focus on applications
in the present.
- Great. Thank you, Federica.
Dmitri?
- Okay.
I work at the intersection of
political economy and
political philosophy,
and I want to,
in my remarks, what I want to do
is to suggest a
perspective on mini-publics
and lottocratic governance
that comes from thinking about
what political economic models
and the particular strategic
models of decision-making
tell us about these things.
And I'd like to talk in
particular about two sets
of political economy models:
models of communication
and models of delegation.
A key result of the strategic
models of communication,
many of which focus on the scenario of
committee decision-making,
committee deliberation prior
to collective policy choice,
is that participant's
willingness to engage
in a kind of open-ended deliberation
is critically conditioned
on their expectations
of how their speech might affect
the ultimate committee decision.
In essence, these models study
the various ways in which
a participant's communication strategy,
what to say,
how to interpret what others say,
whether to speak or listen,
are sensitive to the details
of the policy selection rules
after communication.
And a key expectation here
is that participants
behave in a relatively,
you know, manipulative kind of way,
not as ideal type participants
in what New York and Harvard most called
ideal speech situation
or Josh called an ideal
deliberative position.
Moving on to the strategic
models of delegation,
a key result here is that, by and large,
strong accountability incentives
make for tighter connection
between the interests of the participants
and the principles.
So in the interest of, in particular,
in the interest of the principals voters
and the choices of those
who are making choices
on their behalf, which
is to say politicians,
members of legislative
bodies or executives,
there are some exceptions to this,
such as pandering, for example,
and closely related to that,
perverse effects of transparency.
But those exceptions have to do
not with whether you want accountability,
but whether you want
stricter or weaker incentives
via the accountability channels.
The bottom line from these kinds of models
is that accountability
via selection and treatment mechanisms
is how you make representation work.
So now let's think about the relation
between these expectations,
right from these, you
know, two sets of models:
strategic models of communication
and strategic models of delegation
and the way mini-publics work.
So with respect to the strategic
models of communication,
you take away the binding policy choice
and you remove a key
factor that is responsible
for manipulative communicative posture
that strategic models of
communication describe.
In other words, by taking away
the binding policy decision,
you remove a key impediment
to open-ended deliberative exchange.
Now, there's a worry by
removing an extrinsic motivation
to effect a certain kind of, you know,
binding policy outcome as
a result of communication,
you're also removing incentives to
make careful, kind of
thought out decisions.
But I think what we see
is that citizens juries,
among other types of mini-publics,
replace extrinsic with
intrinsic motivations.
Participants are keen to be there
and to engage with each other.
Of course, this leaves issues on the table
with respect to the relationship
between the distribution
of intrinsic motivations
and the distribution of
participants prior beliefs.
There are demographic
characteristics and so on,
but these are arguably solvable
kind of technical issues,
and the stratification-based
sample selection techniques
are, in fact, increasingly
effective in solving them.
If you now go back to the
strategic models of delegation
that I described,
mini-publics give up
accountability of the represented,
and by doing so, they presumably raise
the specter of decision-making
that does not represent voters' interests.
But because they don't make
binding policy decisions,
the worry is much more attenuated.
If what we have in mind are
consultative point of
information kind of bodies,
the concerns with accountability
are arguably not suppressing.
So both sets of strategic problems
with communication and with
faithful representation
appear to be at least attenuated,
if not entirely eliminated
by the lottery-base
mini-publics being deliberative,
but not ultimately policy-making bodies.
So here comes the challenge, right?
Is this stable in the sense
of equilibrium outcome, right?
Are we improving and refining
the quality of mini-publics?
And as we are doing this,
are we not increasing their attractiveness
as substitute policy makers,
or at least as authoritative
kind of deference-requiring
decision makers?
This is not the point about
whether scholars or activists
are seeking to use mini-publics
as substitutes or supplements
of existing institutions
of electoral democracy,
rather, this is a point about
the equilibrium authority
with which recommendations of mini-publics
would be endowed by the citizens,
which is to say, how
the citizens themselves
would perceive mini-publics.
The more reliable and authoritative
citizens perceive them to be,
and so the more differential to them
the citizens would become,
the stronger the incentives
for the participants
to engage in manipulative speech
and to depart from faithful
representation become,
in other words, the more
relevant the strategic models
of communication and delegation become.
There's a further threat to the stability
of the normatively attractive
model of mini-publics
that relates to Ali's and Brenda's work
that we heard about today.
The more influential the mini-publics are,
the more parties want to control them,
because ultimately,
parties are multidimensional
issue aggregates,
and they're constrained by considerations
of political feasibility
in the way that deliberative
mini-publics are not parties,
and other long-term decision actors
should then be naturally
expected to look for ways
to co-opt and constrain
authoritative mini-publics
to avoid being left holding the bag.
So you can think of the
considerations I described
as a kind of paradox of authority
for lottocratic mini-publics.
The threat to the
authority of mini-publics
is from their becoming authoritative.
But if it is a paradox, it's not the kind
that comes with an absurd proposition
since we can readily make
sense of it analytically.
Whatever it is, I think it raises
a set of important questions
that is worth thinking about,
whether expectations from the many
existing mini-public experiments
can be expected to scale up
and persist over the long run.
What we can plausibly hope,
there are also mini-publics to be,
and, you know, in the long run,
how enthusiastic about them,
ultimately, we should be.
- Thank you, Dmitri.
Phil, go ahead.
- Fascinating. I feel like I need
five minutes to just reflect on it.
I don't know if this is on, but...
Am I loud enough or should I...
- Now, it's on. There we go.
Yeah, that was fascinating
to think through.
And...
So my name's Philip Lindsay.
I lead the Democracy Innovation Hub
at The Hannah Arendt Center, Bard College.
I found myself on the way up
to The Hannah Arendt Center
to a conference that they were running
before I joined two and a half years ago.
The Hannah Arendt Center
has been running conferences
for the past 15 years on different topics:
social media, civil disobedience.
We bring together journalists, activists,
elected officials, writers, thinkers
for a couple days every year.
And for two years, from 2020 and 2021,
the theme of the conference was sortition
and spaces of power.
And...
I was on my way up.
I signed up to attend the conference.
As someone who was on their way
to become a social studies teacher,
I was thinking of...
I just quit my job at a
community outreach center
in Sunset Park, Brooklyn, where I live,
worked at a community health
center for three years,
and was ready to go back into teaching.
I thought that was the best way for me
to be working with young people on civics
and getting young people
engaged in democracy.
That's really what drives me.
This conference blew my mind
because I had no idea about the history
of random selection, sortition,
and it, you know, it made
me feel quite ignorant,
but it's also a failure
of our public school system, I think.
And it totally energized me.
I was feeling quite down
about the possibilities
for comprehensive approaches and solutions
to what we are facing as a society.
I felt like our society
was collapsing around me.
I feel like we were not coming up
with the sort of collaborative
problem-solving mechanisms
that we desperately needed.
And when I started learning
about these assemblies
at the conference,
I was re-energized.
And for the past two and
a half years, essentially,
basically, all of my
time has been dedicated
to organizing a space at the Arendt Center
called the Democracy Innovation Hub
that tries to energize others
around these same issues of same model.
Although I would say we're
not obsessed with one model.
We don't think citizens'
assemblies are gonna save the world
or that there's one type of as assembly
that should be implemented everywhere.
I think what inspired me
and re-energized me was
the idea of bringing everyday people
not just to get to come
into a room and talk,
but to have a sho...
The question that really
has inspired me is,
if you were to design
an ideal learning space
that empowered people to take
action over their own lives
and the lives of their communities,
what would it look like?
I think if you try to answer that,
you get something towards a
citizens' assembly of some sort.
This idea of bringing people together
and intentionally mixing in the society,
intentionally mixing the society,
getting people to see
other parts of the society
that they are not
interacting with every day,
from all kinds, you know,
crossing barriers and neighborhoods,
is something that inspired me.
And...
So what have we been doing at the center?
We've run three major convenings.
The first one was 2022.
We had over 50 participants up
in the Hudson Valley at Bard.
And the intent, similar to an assembly,
is that we try to really
bring together people
that are maybe not talking to each other,
but are somewhat, could be primed
or could be interested in this model.
And we say, "Let's work
together to scale some of these
and co-design them from a
place-based perspective."
That is, let's not just copy
what X, Y, and Z country
or place is doing.
Let's ask what would it mean
to rebuild trust in our locality
from the ground up,
but also from the inside
out and the outside in.
So we've done that,
we've been doing that
in the Hudson Valley.
And so there's working groups
of both elected officials
and everyday people
who have come together to
start exploring these ideas
in and around Bard.
And then we've also done that
in New York City where I live.
You heard from Forest earlier.
Essentially, we've run
these two convenings
and one teacher training workshop,
and the last convening
really brought together
the teachers with the elected officials
and community leaders.
So we had over 140 people in New York City
just a few weeks ago,
and it was a really inspiring
dynamic group of people
exploring models from all over the world.
But then importantly, it wasn't just,
it's like, how do we model this?
Like if you even think about
the way this room is structured,
the way we we're doing public meetings,
the way we do conferences,
if we start thinking with
a design perspective,
we could redesign the way we're doing
a lot of these convenings
to workshop these ideas.
Now, again, this is not coming
from a research perspective.
This is like...
I'm way on the applied side, right?
But the idea is to bring,
to have it be a mix of
academics, practitioners,
advocates, students, young people.
They should be in the room
co-designing these processes,
thinking through how they might work,
how they're affected by them.
And so that last convening we've just done
really is a culmination of a
lot of the work we're doing.
Training teachers,
doing workshops with city agencies,
trying to figure out
how a process might
fit into a city agency,
how a city agency could pilot a process.
And so we workshop two live
initiatives in New York City
in this last convening.
One was Energizing New York
that you heard about earlier today,
and another one was a possible
assembly on some topic
with the Mayor's Office of Engagement
in New York City.
So that's kind of our model is like
you build a space, and
then you ask people,
you invite people in to
co-design the assembly
or the series of assemblies with you.
The last thing I would just say is that
we're at The Hannah Arendt Center,
and there is a deep theoretical
connection to her work
and her, you know, that
conference that inspired me.
This idea of it being a deeply human thing
to need to be seen in public,
to need to appear in
public with other people,
and to take action with other
people as being deeply human
is one of the reasons
we're at the Arendt Center.
And, yeah, I'm happy to be here.
I hope I didn't go over my time.
- You're good, you're great.
Finally, Kris.
- I'll take this out.
Great.
Thank you. It is wonderful to be here,
and I'm really grateful
to be learning from folks
that are so studied
and such deep experts on this issue
on these various approaches to democracy.
And thank you, Ali, for inviting me
and also for hosting this.
I have found it to be so interesting,
and as the neophyte in the room,
I think the resident neophyte,
I'm thrilled to kind of hear about
all the various innovative approaches
that governments, that organizations,
and that certainly researchers
are taking to innovate democracy.
So I come, as Ali mentioned, from Meta,
and I'm thrilled to be
here because at Meta,
we are taking the first
steps that we believe
are important to democratize
inputs into our innovation.
And so my team is the governance team.
We sit at the intersection
of technology and society.
Our mission is to really
elevate user voice
into our innovation.
And so our flagship initiative,
which we launched three years ago is,
as Ali mentioned,
is called the Oversight Board.
It's been termed the
Supreme Court for Facebook,
but essentially, it is a recourse
or redressal mechanism
that everyday users can appeal to.
It's an independent institution
that we established,
but we have enshrined
through a series of bylaws
and governing documents
that has independent decision-making
and binding authority over Meta
when it comes to individual's content.
So if you use one of Meta's platforms
and you disagree with the decision
that we've taken on your content,
for the first time in human history,
you can appeal to an external body
that has binding authority
over the company.
And so we think that that's
a really important first step
in governing the company
and divesting power away
from a small set of
individuals at one company
to have such an impact on things
like freedom of expression.
But we also recognize that, fundamentally,
that is a redressal mechanism
or recourse mechanism,
and so we have been experimenting,
over the past two years,
in deliberative discourse
and deliberative democracy
to democratize inputs into
our innovation at the onset.
So we've been really, really thrilled
to start taking steps in this direction
and to iterate throughout each pilot
that we've pursued.
About two years ago,
we ran our first pilot
that was focused on what we should do
on climate misinformation on our platform.
The second pilot that we
held was about a year ago,
and it was on specific policies
related to the Metaverse.
And then most recently,
we were thrilled to host
a community forum, that's our term for it,
on generative AI and the
principles that should underpin
how we innovate our
generative AI products.
And so I can share just a
little bit about the approach.
Each one has been slightly different.
But we partner,
as a company, we partner with
Stanford's Deliberative Democracy Lab
to do a deliberative poll.
So that's actually the
format of the mechanism.
And then we also partner with
the Behavioural Insights Team,
a behavioral economics organization
and social science firm, to help us design
and to also vet our materials,
and our approach, and our design
to ensure it's as free
as possible from bias.
And so the way that the process works,
and we've been really pleased to date,
but we're also really open
to innovating further,
is that we seek out a
representative sample of the public.
We use a polling firm,
so people don't need to actually
be users on our platforms.
They don't need to have
any specific expertise.
We go out and recruit everyday people
that want to participate.
We then provide them an education packet
with background on the topic
that we are seeking their input on.
That packet has background context.
It's written at an accessible level.
We work with Behavioural
Insights Team to do that,
to make it tangible and accessible.
And then we provide that packet
as a pre-read to participants.
Participants then join the
forum remotely and virtually
through Stanford's deliberative platform
that is AI facilitated,
and guides them through,
without human moderation,
guides the participants through
a series of questions and proposals.
So we may have an overarching topic
that we want their feedback on,
but we provide, in the education material,
a series of different ideas
for how we might approach
a particular problem
and the associated pros and cons
to unpack the tensions that are inherent
within that particular topic.
So, for example, on the most
recent forum on generative AI,
we wanted to hear people's perspectives
on how chatbots should foster
connection with humans.
It's a major topic because
chatbots have such great promise,
and generative AI has such great promise
to alleviate symptoms of loneliness.
There's a growing, small
but growing body of evidence
about its utility and
cognitive behavioral therapy.
But at the same time,
there's also real risks
for people engaging with chatbots.
There was one famous case in Europe
in which one individual committed suicide
after engaging a chatbot,
and it encouraged him to commit suicide.
And so these are technologies
that are transformative
but also have real risk for offline harm.
And so we wanted to ask participants about
what they thought on how chatbot
should establish connections with humans.
And as a part of that,
we would unpack the pros and the cons
of the series of proposals.
The participants enter this platform,
they engage with one another,
they debate and share their perspectives.
We then provide access
to a panel of experts
that have technical expertise,
human rights expertise,
research expertise,
and the participants are
able to ask questions
of these experts.
And then there's a session in which
participants then leave the expert panel,
can debrief with one another
and share what they learned.
And the way that we actually
solicit their direct input
is through a deliberative,
it is a deliberative poll.
And so they take a poll
before and after the forum
so that we can understand how
their views may have changed.
And so we think that this has been
kind of a really great experiment
in deliberative discourse.
Our first kind of
learnings from the pilots,
we're still penning the results
from this particular forum,
but that we've been really thrilled
that people, first of all,
as I think evidenced by all the research
and everything that's been shared here,
people are willing and they're able
to engage deeply with one another
on very complex issues.
And so it gives us great
hope that people can discuss
some of the most pressing
issues of our time
and develop really
rich, meaningful results
through deliberation.
The the other learning is that
people appreciate having a voice.
And that's something that we have found
with the Oversight Board
in terms of empowering people to appeal
to a body that can overrule Meta.
But we also recon,
and I think the data to date in our forms
suggests that people actually,
there's a positive change
in which they have cited
that they have been really
appreciating the experience.
But we also know that these,
the legitimacy of such
systems only matter,
and we've heard this
throughout the day-to-day,
only matter when there's
actually tangible outcomes
that come from these forums.
And so whereas our Oversight Board
has binding authority over Meta,
this model is advisory in nature.
And so what we are doing, moving forward,
is developing a much more robust way
that we can share how
the results of the forum
and how the feedback that we
receive from the participants
actually will inform our
innovation moving forward.
And then lastly, I would
just say that we believe,
through this particular model,
that technology offers a great opportunity
to scale discourse.
And I know a lot of the
deliberative assemblies
in history have been in person.
Given Meta's scale of having
over 3 billion users on our platforms,
and given the global
nature of the company,
we really are looking to technology
to be something that can be an enabler
at the same time that
creates its own set of risks.
Ali was one of our observers
at the forum a couple weeks ago,
and we've had great conversations,
and she's offered great feedback about
the unevenness that comes
inherent with technology.
So there's this great promise of scale,
but also potential risk
of uneven discourse.
And so we're just really looking forward
to continuing to innovate further.
I think I really appreciate the spirit of
kind of, throughout the day,
people talking about different models,
and what might work here
might not work in another context,
and what may have worked in the past
may not necessarily work in the future.
And so we're very open-minded
to continuing to innovate,
but I think our mission,
really, moving forward,
is to continue to solicit input
and to democratize
inputs into the company.
Thanks.
- Excellent. Thank you, Kris.
As you can see, we constructed the panel
with a wide range of viewpoints.
And so now we're going to discuss
a lot of pressing issues about lotteries
that tap into each of the
panelists' individual expertise.
We're gonna start with the big one,
kind of the elephant in the room,
which is, assume that democracy is dying
and elections are broken.
Should we just get rid of elections?
Should we make a radical change
and stop electing our politicians,
so our congressmen
or our parliamentarians,
if you're in Europe,
and switch to a
sortition-based institution?
Is that possible? Should we do it?
Dmitri or Federica,
if one of you wanna take this one.
- Okay, I'll start.
I have a sense that, you know,
defenses of mini-publics
often have two components:
a kind of a very pessimistic,
almost mordant element,
and highly optimistic,
you know, sometimes even joyous one.
The pessimistic has to do
with the existing electoral institutions
and the optimistic one has to do with,
you know, wonderful replacements
that are being suggested,
including, of course,
lottocratic institutions.
And I'm not sure that this is
an apples to apples comparison.
I think there's a kind of a
tendency that goes with this,
of course, to see the status quo,
to treat the status quo institutions
as the proper benchmark version
of representative democracy.
This is it, folks, right?
That, like that.
And if it is, then maybe
we should get rid of elections, right?
Maybe that's right.
But that seems a little too hasty.
And I don't think that
the status quo version
of representative democracy
is the proper benchmark version,
and so I do think it's a comparison
of an apple to an orange,
a kind of inferior institutional
form of electoral regime
to potentially superior,
or arguably superior,
within the set of lottocratic regimes
on institutional form of another,
you know, if we're
talking about lottocracies
or if we're talking about
modified direct democracies,
some kind of modified
direct democracy version,
which is to say, I don't think
that's a fair comparison.
There are many ways, it seems to me,
in which we might go about
reforming electoral systems from within
without giving up on the idea
of electoral representation
or of political accountability
on which the idea of electoral
representation rests.
One important principle
of institutional design
that I think kind of
speaks to many concerns
that lottocratic critics
of elections have raised
is that it's a very intuitive idea
that we should seek to minimize
the influence of the political actors
over the rules of their
own political contests.
The basic intuition there
is that it's precisely
that kind of influence
that gives rise to
corrupted electoral system,
and of course, very few
electoral regimes today
come anywhere close to
implementing this principle.
So it seems to me that there are,
and this is just one example,
but it seems to me that
there are many ways
in which we might look
to institutionalized
something like this,
including, by the way,
via something like,
you know, randomly selected
electoral commissions
that Christian was speaking
about earlier today.
So there's a lot of room for innovation
and improvement from within
the electoral system.
So I think it's too hasty.
- Yeah, I agree with that.
And I'm just gonna add one thing.
I don't think,
I guess I'm challenging the
premise on a different aspect,
I don't think that democracy is dy,
if democracy is dying,
I don't think that democracy is dying
because of elections,
or uniquely because of elections.
And what I see in the
research that I conduct on
pre-modern democracies
or collective governance
is that elections are, in fact,
an element in the soup
of collective governance.
And so what seems to me, urgent, however,
is to question the role of elections
as a unique sort of like a form
for eliciting the popular preferences
and to identify the proper space
for electoral politics
vis-a-vis lottocratic policy
or other types of policy.
The problem, however, seems to me,
and I think that the
discussion that we had today
sort of like cemented some of the ideas
that I arguably came into
this conference with,
which is that we really
lack the social science
to address this question
to properly understand the relative value
and the scope of different
types of selection mechanisms.
And what worries me is that,
again, as a social scientist,
I think that we do really
need to put some of our brains
onto this question of trying to understand
the relative scope and value
of different mechanisms.
But listening to, you know, practitioners,
I wonder if, you know,
how the social science
actually needs to be integrated
and integrate with experiments,
particularly, experiments
where we see like
sort of an attempt to just
come into the room, saying,
"Forget what we know about the past,
let alone what happened five minutes ago."
Then to think about like how
to co-design these spaces,
I'm really of two minds
about what the relative value
of each approach might be,
and I think that, ultimately,
we might need both.
- And, you know, both
panelists bring up a good point
in that there are many
ways to use lotteries.
And actually, our ability
as social scientists
to collect empirical data
on the highest levels
is really hard, right,
because these are governing institutions
with real life politicians,
parties that are established.
But we see a new wave,
a deliberative wave,
of institutions being
implemented all over.
So citizens' assemblies,
or redistricting, or Oversight Boards.
And so maybe this is the future.
And I was wondering, Phil,
could you maybe argue for
including more deliberative institutions
or the types of activities
that your organization does?
Where should we start?
If not at the very top,
where should we start?
At maybe local levels,
and getting local governments involved
to incorporate lotteries
- Yeah, absolutely.
The way I've been thinking about this
and the way I think a lot of people...
I mean, I say a lot like
the handful of folks
who are also in educational institutions,
which are naturally anchor institutions
in communities, right?
They order food from a
local catering company,
they serve students, right,
especially if they're a public school.
Is how do you think about re, you know,
reinvigorating local democracy
from a place-based perspective?
What I've been really
inspired by is this idea
that Federica kind of hinted at,
which is experimenting
and collaborating with both academics,
but then, you know,
local teachers, community leaders,
on some hard issue
that's actually happening
in the community.
So for instance,
in Lancaster, Pennsylvania
at Franklin & Marshall,
they've been running
deliberative forums there,
you know, at the university
space for the past year.
I only found out about
this a couple weeks ago,
but I was immediately inspired to say,
"Yeah, that's a great model
that we can take back to Bard.
We have not been running
deliberative forums."
A big part of what the way I see these
and the way we see them
at the Arendt Center
is as schools,
as like gyms for democracy, right?
Again, I said, if you're
gonna design a space
that gives people the practical tools
for practicing democracy,
it would look something
like a citizens' assembly.
So...
I mean, sitting in a classroom
and learning about civics
in a passive way is just it.
I don't know if it was
ever a good idea, you know?
I don't know if that was ever design...
I don't know if it was
good for the 20th century,
I doubt it.
I think the things that
inspired me to be a citizen
were going out and working on campaigns
that mattered to me when I was 17.
That's why I'm still involved in poli,
you know, policy or democracy in some way.
And so if you give young
people, especially,
but also just community members,
a different way to engage,
and you empower them,
and you also mix them with other folks
that they wouldn't normally encounter,
through some deliberative experience,
but in a very structured way,
again, I think, like, we're often blind
to the amazing sort of capacity of,
our human capacity to facilitate.
We don't engage in that.
We don't build that muscle in our society.
Like, we don't build that
collaborative muscle.
And I think if we started to think about
what would it mean to give young people
the muscles and the capacity
to facilitate dialogue in their community,
like that's a win no matter what.
We can start doing that.
I don't, I mean, maybe there's a...
I'd love to hear
counterargument against this,
but, like, problem solving,
active listening,
psychosocial skills that enable people
to collaborate on better problems.
Like, I'm sure Meta would
love to hire more people
that are good at that, right?
So I think if we start doing that,
as educational institutions,
on real existing projects, locally,
partnering with elected officials
who want to facilitate some
deliberative processes,
not just deliberations,
but also leading to action,
that's the way we've
been thinking about it
from the Democracy Innovation Hub
is like bringing all those
folks that we can together,
being anchored in one place.
So not trying to say like,
"This is some solution,"
but bringing people in
to think through this.
And be inspired by the
international examples.
Like, that's the one
thing we've really seen
that when you bring people in
and give them case studies of like,
"Look, Bogota in Columbia is doing this.
Like, why don't we try it?" Right?
Like, people need that right now.
People are, especially young people,
are deeply cynical about
the systems we're in.
So we need to come up with ways
to give them pathways to action
that are not just,
"look at how bad everything is," you know?
- Okay. So we need to be more optimistic
and give the youth of today
more opportunities to
get involved in politics
that may be non-traditional.
So it's not just go vote,
but it's, you know,
develop policy positions
with people you might never have
encountered before.
- Can I say
one more thing about that?
- Yeah, please. Yeah.
- Okay. So that's one thing, right?
I've worked on a lot of campaigns,
and I've been burnt out by campaigns.
When you work in this political system,
you try to achieve a certain goal,
and your whole outlook is,
"I'm gonna try to get as many votes
or as many X, Y, Z,
and then it's all or nothing."
That, it's good...
Sometimes, it is all or nothing,
and it's good to have that spirit,
but, like, especially young people
are craving that sort of,
Christian, in your presentation,
you mentioned that,
like the call to action,
the public service.
We are just failing to say,
"To have ambition about
what it would look like
if we called the public to action
in a non-dogmatic ideological way,
in a problem solving way."
I think, so I think...
Yeah, I think that aspect
of like getting young people involved
in re-energizing democracy
that isn't just about
a specific campaign or
a specific individual,
like getting someone elected,
that's necessary.
I'm absolutely against replace,
like, getting rid of elections,
like, or having that framework right now.
But I think that model
does lead to burnout
and disappointment
because if you think
you're gonna win everything
by getting one person in office,
like, you're delusional.
But young people want to be a part
of those kind of campaigns.
- No, I think that's absolutely right.
I'm gonna use that as
a segue to talk about
how not just young people,
but society is changing
and that we're going digital.
We got our information
from different sources.
We just, you know,
lived through a pandemic
where Zoom and other kind of
forms of digital communication
became our lifeline for a while.
And what's interesting
if we think about scale
and how to involve more people
in deliberative activities,
I think, actually, Meta is a incredibly,
a fascinating example of this.
Now, I got to be an observer,
and it was a remarkably well run platform.
The groups were engaging.
You know, the groups kinda acted,
if you teach, right,
how do you get students to
discuss in a deliberate forum?
You know, how do you get
someone from Florida,
someone who's Zooming in from New York,
someone who's from a, you
know, who worked in AI
versus who's worried about
losing their job in AI.
It was a fascinating experience,
and maybe the future, right?
So if Meta is experimenting,
doing this at scale,
and bringing deliberative institutions
into a different, to industry,
not democracy, right, to industry,
I think that's incredibly promising.
So I wanna hear a little
bit more, Kris, about,
you know, do you think
that this is something
Meta will continue with?
Obviously, you've had positive experience,
but does the platform see
it as a positive experience?
Are you going to keep expanding
so millions of users will give input
about issues of today?
What do you think the future of this is?
- Yeah, I think it's,
I mean, great question.
So it is interesting because,
actually, in one of our pilots
to establish proof of concept of scale,
the Metaverse Community Forum,
which I mentioned, which a pilot,
it was a year ago,
actually, it was larger
than this more recent one
on generative AI.
It was 6,000 people across 30 countries
in 23 languages.
What we understood may have been,
although I can't necessarily
prove the negative,
but may have been the
largest deliberative exercise
at once in human history.
And so certainly scale the technology
allows for scale that is,
I think, probably rises to the
needs of this moment, right,
where trust in institutions are collapsing
kind of globally, right?
And so, and there's less and less
confidence in institutions.
And so that may require,
and particularly in emerging technologies,
that no no boundaries may require
global solutions or global input.
So I think the technology, you know,
we think that it should
be a part of the solution
because these technologies
are transformative
in what they can bring to society,
but they're also, as we've
seen in recent history,
transformative in some of the risks.
And so we have been
really kind of thrilled
with the way that this enables scale.
Again, it can also create unevenness.
But there's also other
experiments happening as well.
So I have to acknowledge kind
of other industry efforts
to democratize inputs.
Anthropic recently published a blog
where they used the software Polis
to do something called
Collective Constitutional AI.
So Anthropic kind of
released their constitution,
maybe a year ago,
called Constitutional AI
that underpinned kind of
the rules and the paradigm
in which their chatbot Claude
will operate based off of.
And more recently, they used Polis,
which is a kind of real time
AI-facilitated crowdsourcing tool,
to gather more perspectives from people
and then inform kind of a
different Constitutional AI.
So, the Minister of Digital
Affairs in Taiwan, Audrey Tang,
is doing something similar using,
not just related to AI,
but using Polis software to
crowdsource her populace,
the Taiwanese population,
to inform kind of where there's alignment
on certain policy issues
or where there's polarization.
And so, you know,
yes, I think Meta were
really, really excited
about the community forum.
We're really excited about this platform
that can enable discourse at scale.
We obviously saw during the pandemic,
because Zoom,
there was Zoom fatigue, famously,
but even if it's not
that particular platform
or that particular model,
there's other organizations
experimenting with technology.
I think it has to be the future.
But in the spirit of innovation
and everything I've heard here,
I think that it would be
anyone that's in this space
to really iterate further.
And I was really struck
by Federica's comments
earlier in her talk about, you know,
maybe the model isn't necessarily
the same in every region,
maybe you need to meet
regions where they are
based on their cultural context.
And so maybe you have a
much more flexible model,
all enabled by technology maybe,
but maybe you change the model
depending on where you are,
depending about those individual needs.
- [Announcer] Can I have
your attention, please?
- Actually, I was about to wrap up.
So anyways, I would just say,
I think technology is super exciting,
also, you know, relatively untested,
and we should continue to innovate.
- Federica, do you have a follow up on
kind of digital collective governance
or anything about the new online sphere
we find ourselves in?
- Yeah, and maybe this will
sound peculiar said by me,
but I think that the idea that we would
sort of like a self defeatingly,
eliminate the affordances
that technology gives us
for participation, for collaboration,
would be absurd and detrimental, I think.
And so in a world in which we necessarily
sort of engage with technology
to achieve these types of radically,
perhaps, decentralized and at scale forms
of collaboration and participation,
I think that, as Kris
has already suggested,
we need to be very much
aware of the pitfalls.
And I think that there is
one particular pitfalls
that I am concerned about
when it comes to technology-mediated,
particularly generative AI-mediated
collaboration and participation, which is,
essentially, like what both Philip
and Forest earlier discussed,
at the heart of the sort of engagement
and participation that they see,
which is this texture of civic norms
and of just like collaborative norms
that is built, I think, more likely
in spaces where people come together,
physically, and engage.
And now, this might be
empirically incorrect.
I stand to be sort of like a proven false,
but I think that it is
something truly to consider
the degree to which
online virtual engagements
make us even more exposed
to the possibility
of missing out on this fundamental
sort of like a texture of social norms.
That is essentially
what brings us together
and what makes democracy work.
And so that's, I think,
something that any use of
technology in these spaces
would have to consider.
- Hmm.
- And the last question,
anyone can take this
before we open it up to the audience.
So technological advances
means it's easier
to talk to folks who are
not physically present.
So maybe our communication
ability has increased.
But we are also in a world,
many places, there's
a lot of polarization,
and particularly, effective
polarization, right?
So we seem like we're more divided
even though it's easier to talk.
And when we think about who participates
in deliberative mini-publics,
who responds to the
invitation to go debate
with fellow citizens for a weekend,
giving up kind time and effort,
should we be worried that...
Maybe not in all places,
but in some countries,
the US in particular.
It's, you know, it's
more common in Europe,
all of these institutions,
than it is in the US.
Is this something we
should be concerned about?
Do people not wanna talk
to each other anymore?
And so either the practitioners
who have gotten people together
or academics who have studied
and thought about
polarization at institutions,
anyone can take this,
but should we be worried that polarization
will slow down the benefits
of deliberative democracy?
- I'll take that.
- Go ahead.
- I think one of the
dangers of polarization
is this kind of siloed
learning through reinforcement
by passively observing others
rather than engaging
deliberatively with them,
and passively observing others
who are essentially like us.
I think it's the kind of thing that,
you know, that leads...
It's less about immediate affect
and more about arriving at
posterior beliefs and positions
that are potentially mistaken,
that are influenced by signals from others
that are not independent signals,
that are sort of from the set of people
who are very much like us.
It's the kind of thing that
leads to people arriving at,
people coming to view themselves
as having very strong posteriors
such that there's no point
in engaging in deliberation.
So it's a substitution
of kind of passively reinforced beliefs
for proactively searching
debate or conversation.
It's a process that generates
relatively stable contentious posteriors
without turning into kind of a contentious
but open-ended and possibly
corrective discourse.
I'm worried about that as
an effect of polarization.
So it's not so much an effect,
but this kind of effect on how we perceive
the nature of the disagreement
and our own beliefs relative
to the disagreement.
- Phil, have you seen this
in your practitioning?
- I would say, being at Bard,
a progressive liberal arts
college in the Hudson Valley,
I've been of two minds.
One is we need to put out the call
as quickly and as strongly as possible
that there are other modes
of engaging in democracy.
Citizens' assemblies are,
it's a sort of call to action, right?
The issue is that the people
who are primed for that,
even at this point, primed for
even the word for democracy,
are somewhere to the left of
where the right is right now.
So...
You're...
It's an uphill battle to sort
of reach across the aisle,
and sometimes it feels
like a naive attempt
or like, let's say this,
I try to avoid the sort of
the partisan polarization,
because I think if you get
in like, "Oh, we're gonna try
to get the reds and the
blues in the room together,"
it kind of misses the point
where it's like most people
probably don't associate
with, like, as a red or a blue,
Republican, Democrat.
So if you try to take the
place-based perspective
and say like, "Anyone out there
who wants to try to create a better,
sort of more collaborative
form of democracy,"
like even thinking through the language
on how we talk about citizens' assemblies
is like, one of the things...
You know, at first it was the sort,
it was the sortition project at Bard,
and it was just like no
one knows what that is.
Sounds super academic.
People are gonna write it off
as like some idea, like, okay.
Now it's the Democracy Innovation Hub.
After our last conference, we were like,
"Should we call it the
Center for Citizen Power?"
You know, like...
Because there's a question
of how to relate to
in this rapidly polarized, like, world
in which language is changed so quickly.
I think we just have to make the effort
and not worry too much about...
Like, I think if the intention is there
to meet people where they're at
and to be open about disagreement,
about tough issues,
I think that's the most important thing.
But I would say, like,
the people that tend to
come to us or email me
have like participated in
participatory budgeting, right?
Like, they're...
So there's gotta be an
intention from these efforts
as we're organizing them,
both as citizens or as
educational institutions,
to say, "We're gonna do as best as we can
to, you know, reach
across different aisles
or reach across different
sections of the population
without, you know, reproducing
the sort of stereotype
of that idea that already exists."
I don't know if that helps
answer the question at all.
- No, and I mean, recruitment
and getting the word out
that there are these positive experiences
from deliberative mini-publics
or participatory budgeting,
that is also,
the more the work of the
people in this room expands,
the more people will know.
And that's also one of the
goals of this conference.
So we're actually gonna
open it up to the audience.
So audience members,
if you could raise your hand very high
and Pam will come and
give you a microphone.
And please introduce yourself when you...
- So hi, everyone.
I'm Helene Landemore.
I'm professor of Political
Science at Yale University.
I think some of you, at least maybe,
will know me as one of the
optimists about mini-publics
and pessimists about electoral democracy.
And thank you so much for this
conference and this panel.
It's truly extraordinary, I think,
and very symbolically also, I think,
that it's one of the first
conferences on lotteries
that I think has taken place here.
I don't think I organize
one, I should have,
but anyway, that's you.
(everyone laughing)
So I have question for each
of you, if I'm allowed.
So Federica first.
I was wondering if you had
thoughts on how the Greeks,
the ancient Greeks,
solves the objections raised by Dmitri.
So how come they,
for, let's say, 200 years,
did without elections
and yet were relatively stable
and didn't get captured,
at least, you know,
in a way that damages our system too much
by, I don't know, local economic elites
like hot, what.
So Dmitri, it's a question to you as well.
Does the Greek case answer
some of your questions or not,
or is it a completely different case?
Because we're not talking about
the transition from an electoral system
to a, you know, mini-public based system,
but it's a completely different system
that never had elections
for our political functions.
I have a question for Kris.
Very nice to meet you.
I am excited to hear more about
what you're doing at Meta.
So given the objections
from Dmitri, again,
about, you know, what happens
when you don't give people
real power, in particular,
and the risk of, you know,
losing their interest or motivation,
and your own claim that you're
looking to make the opinions
of the participants a bit more binding,
shouldn't you move towards
more of a citizens'
assembly model, actually,
where it's not just about
polling people at the end,
but getting them to
deliberate towards a goal,
towards a recommendation,
towards a binding resolution,
and then they would function more
like your Oversight Board, potentially?
Just a thought.
And also, I have to ask,
like, what have you learned at Meta
from the OpenAI governance, you know,
or board failure of the last week?
I would love to hear what you have to say
because they were
structured as a non-profit
and that board totally failed.
You are structured as a for-profit
and you are seemingly
successfully equipping yourselves
with constraints of some sort.
I don't know how, you know,
constrained they really are,
but they look like they could be.
Dmitri, now,
I would love to be less of a pessimist
about electoral systems
and so I'm willing to believe
that under some different circumstances,
somewhere, they could be great.
But I'd like to hear what do you think
is the standard of success,
and how do you address the
criticism one could make
based on the sort of a
plutocratic tendencies
of those systems?
There's an article
in the British Journal
of Political Science
that came out in June
that shows that across,
like, 30 countries,
40 years, 2,000 issues,
there's a systematic over representation
or over congruence,
greater congruence with the
preferences of rich people
in these countries.
You know, policies match their preferences
more than they match the preferences
of poor people, for example.
Or majorities even.
So that seems to be a systematic problem,
and maybe there's a trade off
there that I'm not seeing,
that we're gaining more competence,
we're gaining something,
stability or better
protection of minority,
you know, in exchange for
that plutocratic bias,
but I would love to hear what it is.
Did I, oh yeah.
And Philip, I have a question for you too.
I hear about your work and how seemingly,
you know, officials at the city level,
maybe the state level,
are getting somewhat interested
in mini-publics and lotteries,
but somehow, at the federal level,
I find it very dispiriting how,
you know, the democracy
summits organized by Biden
systematically failed to
mention deliberative democracy,
mini-publics, lotteries.
It's not at all on their agenda.
Why is that?
And what can be done?
Thank you. Sorry it was very long, but...
- Excellent questions.
We'll just go...
Federica, if you wanna start,
we'll go down the table.
- Okay.
Hi, Helene. Thank you for the question.
So the Greeks, the Athenians
didn't have elections.
They used elections to
select a few magistrates.
We don't have evidence of
elections in the large bodies
that we associate with the democracies,
the courts, the assembly, and the council.
But this is, I guess,
it is certainly a situation
in which there isn't a full fledged
electoral democratic system
that then needs to be replaced
with a lottocratic or other
types of institutions,
but the Greeks were certainly not unaware
of elections as a mechanism.
I think that as far as we can tell
by looking at people that have studied
these questions extensively,
democracy without elections
in the vast majority
of sort of like what is
the decision-making process
in a situation that didn't lead to,
either lead capture,
but also, and I think
that this is the problem
that the situation in
Athens really generated,
which is the avoidance of elite capture
is one aspect of the story,
the other aspect of the story
is the avoidance of popular ignorance.
So how do a bunch of
people sitting on a hill
decide on matters of war
and peace and finance
without really being experts?
This is Plato's problem.
And I think that some of the authors
that have looked at this question,
including, of course, Josh Ober,
have really looked at
the political discourse,
at the texture of civic norms,
and how very simple
mechanisms for selection,
for decision-making,
created a situation in which people
shared information and learned
from coming together in this public body.
So again, I think that my work today
is sort of like a pushing against the idea
that we should continue to
obsess with Ancient Athens,
but others remains a fundamental
sort of like a place to learn
about ancient democracies
and pre-modern democracies.
- Okay, Dmitri.
- So I'm going to defer to Federica
on all questions having
to do with Ancient Athens.
I do want to respond to Helene's question
about how to think about
the relative advantages,
at least in principle, relative advantages
of representative democracy.
I think one dimension
where there is something to be said,
in particular, about representation
has to do with complexity of governance.
I think direct democratic forms,
lottocratic forms are
particularly attractive
when issue dimensions can be isolated
and dealt with in an isolated way
without generating massive externalities
with respect to other dimensions.
I think when you talk about policy making
that has these kinds of-
- [Announcer] May I have
your attention, please.
- So I think when you
talk about policy making
with respect to issues
that have these kinds of
cross issue externalities,
I think that's where there is some value.
There's considerable value,
I would say, right,
for something like
representative electoral process
with policy makers who are
given a jurisdiction right
that encompasses multiple issues.
And I think that's where, you know...
And I think our world
is sort of increasingly like that, right?
Or has been increasingly like that for,
you know, for, at least for
the last two plus millennia
since, you know, since Ancient Athens.
So that's the way I would
direct the argument.
- Okay, Phil.
- Okay.
So I think
we need to run workshops in DC
with federal government officials,
and we just...
Basically, we need to find more folks
who are willing to organize,
knock doors, talk,
call elected officials.
I think it's already happening,
and I don't even think,
I know that there's other people out there
starting to do this work
that haven't connected
'cause we haven't had
enough of these convenings.
So I just came back from DC yesterday
at the National Conference on Citizenship,
the Future of Citizenship,
and there was a workshop
with Marjan Ehsassi
and Jillian Youngblood and John Gastil
on citizens' assemblies
at the National Conference of Citizenship.
There's now a Democracy Innovation Center
within the National Civic League.
And I think, basically,
(announcer faintly speaking)
we need to organize...
I just...
I'm like my...
(announcer faintly speaking)
Yes, I think we basically
need to organize convenings,
and I think it would be great
if Bard, and Yale,
and other colleges thought of this
from a collaborative
mindset instead, like...
That's the other thing, like,
all of these institutions are set up
to have a competitive mindset.
If we got together and said,
"How do we scale more
collaborative attempts at this,
together rather than separately,
I think we could have a bigger impact."
Obviously, it cannot just be,
like, elite institutions;
it's gotta be from a
multi-stakeholder perspective.
But these convenings
where anchor institutions have the space
and the convening space, I think,
I mean, one thing over
the next couple months,
and especially this year, 2024,
if we can channel some convenings
not to run citizen assemblies,
but to do things that
are workshopping ideas
and calling out to people,
'cause this year,
a lot of people are gonna be like,
"I don't like either of these candidates.
I'm depressed about the way this is going.
I wish there was some way
for me to get involved."
So, my pitch is let's convene
a lot of those actors,
and then bring in the elected officials,
and do this multi-stakeholder,
these convenings and workshop ideas,
from multiple angles.
And I think, we'll be successful.
I think politicians would...
There are going to be politicians
who start to embrace this
as the next form of democracy
from younger generations, especially.
- And also for the graduate
students in the room,
this sounds like a great idea
for a future dissertation
or future research.
Okay, Kris, finally,
- Wonderful.
Thank you for the questions.
Really nice to meet you.
I am, as I've mentioned,
a neophyte in this space,
but very, have followed your work
and very much an admirer.
So on the citizens' assembly
or the construct that we're using,
deliberative polling
versus citizens' assembly,
I think, open to innovation, right?
I think there's a couple different factors
that are unique to a corporate setting
that we just need to be mindful of
when creating these types of mechanisms.
As far as I know,
there's not a lot of
companies that have done this.
And so I think we're trying
to find our way through it
in a way that is as
productive as possible,
that gives, that honors
the spirit of these mechanisms,
while also recognizing the,
like, unique constraints
of operating in a for-profit company.
And so the deliberative polling method
seems to be efficient, scalable,
kind of also recognizes that
the nature of technology
is so fast evolving.
And so the questions
that we might be asking
may not necessarily be the same things
as a government may be asking citizens
to weigh in on a citizens' assembly.
The generative AI community
forum, for example,
is much more directional
since generative AI is different
than it was six months ago,
it's gonna be different in
six months in the future,
and so we are looking
for directional feedback
rather than some sort of
specific policy outcome.
But I think, you know,
we have not put to bed
any other type of model,
and I think we're very open to it.
So we'd love to continue the conversation,
but this, we think, is
kind of the first step
towards democratizing inputs
in a way that elevates user voice,
but it does so at the
onset of our innovation
rather than something that's a redress
or a recourse mechanism.
On the OpenAI thing,
you know, corporate structure,
I'm not really an expert in that.
I understand the non-profit
versus for-profit structure.
I think, for me, it
just actually reaffirms
the need to infuse democratic inputs,
infuse governance into innovation.
Because if you're relying
on a corporate structure to do that,
like a non-profit board,
that clearly is not,
it's not impervious to potential corrupt,
I don't wanna say corruption,
but potential challenges, right?
And so I think, if anything,
it just shows that we need to actually
imbue our innovation with governance,
and that's why I'm excited to work on it.
- Okay. Other questions from the audience?
Kevin.
- Thanks. Yes.
This is fascinating and interesting
to have all these different perspectives.
So my question might,
it's coming from a little
bit from this question
about sort of the top down,
why is there no interest in
this at the federal level?
So one of the...
So the sort of question
I would pose is like,
absent to revolution,
how would you get from
here to there, right?
How would you get from here to lottocracy?
So think about this in terms of,
absent to revolution,
this is gonna require elected officials
to transfer authority, right?
They're gonna have to adopt these
institutions for some reason.
So that seems, to me, suggest like
one set of questions that we
might have answers to them
or wanna have answers to.
What can deliberate mini-publics
do for elected leaders?
And I don't just mean things like,
we can prove our democracy,
they're not really gonna
care about that, right?
What can it do for them
in a more mercenary way?
Now, that mercenariness can be
a bunch of different things.
One thing would be like,
it takes an issue like
abortion off our plates, right?
In Ireland, one of the
reason they want to do this
'cause they did not want
deal with this question,
and marriage equality,
that's gonna blow up our party
if we try to deal with that.
Another sort of possibility,
and here is one that
I know the beginning of the story
but not the end.
So Mike Neblo,
for a while, was doing these.
It was my understanding he
had members of Congress,
especially freshmen,
were going to engage in these forums
where they spoke with their
randomly selected constituents, right?
And so...
'Cause one of the big
challenges here is...
One way of thinking about this is
getting citizens to trust
deliberate mini-publics,
but what about getting elected officials,
who are the ones who were gonna
have to transfer authority
to these institutions,
how do you get them to trust them?
So I don't know how Mike's
thing has turned out.
I know he did some pilots,
but then he thought he
was doing a bigger one.
So I wonder what you
guys think about that.
I wonder if you know
how this has turned out,
maybe other people in the room do.
So, yeah, so that's sort of my question.
How can we do that?
And then...
Because I feel like
that might be a solution
to some of these questions
about scaling up,
some of these questions about,
also the attractiveness, right?
If there's not a way to
get from here to there,
if there's not a way
to answer that question
of what can this do for politicians,
absent revolution,
then you might be out of luck.
- I'll answer. You were
looking at me mostly.
So I was like..
(everyone laughing)
I think we asked them.
So what we've been doing
before, and I've been doing,
is call up the mayor's office,
we email this other agency,
we email the Department of Transportation,
we email the senators,
we, you know, like, write Joe Biden.
You know, not write to Joe Biden.
That's a bad idea.
But basically, what are you,
what is really hard?
And this is a model.
We're not willing to just
like spend all of our time
doing something for you as a PR
or like engagement trick
that you're trying to run, right?
Like we're citizens,
we think this model could
be the future of democracy,
what are you willing
to do power sharing on,
or to think through?
Or what is some issue
that could be really hard?
That is an open question
that we have to go to the agencies,
and we have to...
Like, basically, the things we've learned
from the folks in like Australia
or healthy democracy, all, you know,
we've been learning from folks
who've been doing this for decades,
and they go and they ask,
"What is really difficult?"
Like, what's the most
difficult thing you face?
And then they workshop different topics,
and then you have to
figure out trade offs,
and you think...
I think that starts a conversation,
and then other conversations open up.
Like, we've been working
with the Mayor's Office
of Engagement in New York
and it turns out that, you know,
that's a unique office
because they serve as a coordinating role
for all public engagement
up from the city side.
So they have unique insights,
and they say, "Well, you know..."
So there's a whole
conversation that opens up,
and then there's a conversation
of how do we, as citizens,
relate to this office, right?
'Cause it's trust building.
When we started doing it, I honestly,
we've built trust in a way,
in having that conversation
from the inside and the outside.
So I think, like,
we basically need to reach out
and ask them how, you know,
what are the ways they would
interact with this model?
And then we learn, oh, some people
want to use it for bad reasons.
We don't wanna work with them.
Some people have really good ideas.
Maybe there's already an existing thing
that they're doing in their
agency that is a lot like this
or some citizen oversight board
that we could help them implement.
It doesn't have to be
a citizens' assembly.
It's more like,
let's meet people where they're at
and workshop these ideas.
That's been our approach.
- And also, sorry, if I can just jump in.
One model to look at is Belgium
that has deliberative committees
that bring together elected politicians
and randomly selected citizens
to debate with each other.
So politicians are going to learn about
the efficacy of deliberative democracy.
That is one way
where if you treat all
of those politicians,
or at least we should
be looking to Belgium
to see if politicians,
those politicians who have experienced
deliberative committees
are more likely to support
the implementation of this
institution in other levels.
Okay, another question.
Oh, I'm sorry. Yeah, Dmitri, go ahead.
- I think deliberative mini-publics
give an opportunity to politicians
who do not want to pander,
right, to an opportunity
to create an independent
source of information
that might have some standing
among their constituency
and enable them to avoid pandering.
So I think there is that kind of an...
Obviously, it's not true
of every politician;
it's true of politicians who, you know,
who would welcome an
opportunity to take a position
that's different from the
one that they're taking,
and that could enable them to do that.
- I have just something
slight to add onto that.
- Go ahead.
Aside from my role at Meta,
at University of Maryland,
I believe his name's Steven Kull,
runs the Voice of the People,
which is a deliberative poll outfit.
They specifically engage constituents
and do deliberative polls
to address polarization,
to show members of Congress that actually,
when given information
and opportunity to
engage with one another,
people are not actually as polarized,
and to, hopefully,
to encourage members of Congress
to change positions on certain issues.
So it's not the same, but just another way
that people are using deliberation
to support the overall kind of system.
- Okay, we have time
for one more question.
Do we have another question?
Yeah, right there, Pam.
Eliza.
- Hey, I'm Eliza Oak,
PhD candidate in Poli Sci here at Yale.
So I'm curious how you think about
which decisions are better suited
for collective decision-making
in the first place,
as opposed to which
decisions should be made
by a smaller group of
experts and representatives.
For example, do you think,
you know, we should optimize around
what are the most controversial decisions
that the public's divided on
in hopes of these discussions
could kind of, you know,
encourage dialogue,
broader consensus,
or, of course, there's
other considerations,
maybe, you know,
making sure the topic is
sufficiently approachable
and not too complex.
But I'm curious, especially
for the practitioners,
how you think about that in practice.
- Do you want it?
- No, no, please.
- Thanks, Eliza, and I'm a
big fan of your work too.
I love the article that
you wrote with Andy Hall,
and you can teach me about web3
and decentralized governance anytime.
Maybe I can just share a little bit
of how we're thinking about it.
I think, probably, it's gonna
be a little bit different
from some folks that focus
more on public institutions.
The way that we have
thought about it to date is,
because, actually, right now,
I mean, there's obviously
things that are highly contested
around social media and technology,
but because a lot of the
technology is emerging,
what we've found is actually like,
you know, things on the Metaverse,
or things even on generative AI,
they're not super polarized yet.
So for us, we were looking
for a lot of gray space
where there's not really necessarily
a clear guiding perspective
either in public or at the company.
So there's may not polarized perspectives,
but maybe just like a lack of consensus
where we could explore and probe.
Again, coming from a
for-profit organization,
also something that we're confident
that we would actually want to
hear public input on, right?
There are some decisions
that the company is gonna say
is within the company's domain,
but that we would actually
be able to valuable,
actually be able to solicit and put on.
And then the other one is around,
you know, how do we
bring participants along,
and is it something that
it's not so technical
that we could actually, you know,
enable through deliberation, education,
and expert engagement
that people to have a rich discussion
and give us valuable feedback,
and something that they can
actually participate in.
And so, you know, we found,
certainly, through all of our pilots,
that we were impressed by the richness
of the discussions and the deliberations
even on things that are pretty technical.
But you can imagine that coming
from a technology company,
there are things that are so,
and actually things like web3,
I mean, I'm not convinced that everyone
would be able to grasp
every technical detail
about our technology,
and so finding something
that is fit for purpose,
for deliberation in terms
of the accessibility
of the topic as well.
- Okay. Phil, final response.
A brief one if you can.
- Yeah, I'd just point to Forest.
I don't think you saw Forest's
presentation this morning,
but it's recorded.
So he went through sort of the way
we thought about a
democratically legitimate way
to arrive at an issue in New York City
around energy and climate, for instance,
which you might have some formal body,
team of experts,
whether it's the New
York version of the IPCC,
deliver sort of the,
or a team of university sort of professors
who have studied the
biggest climate impacts
or the biggest challenges
facing the energy system
in New York, right?
Or the energy transition.
And then, you know, list out those five,
and then have a citywide poll of some sort
or an engagement mechanism
in which everyday people are saying,
"Oh, we wanna be involved with that."
They've also done this in...
Oh, I'm actually blanking
on where they did this, but basically...
Oh, in Belgium, I think.
On the deliberative committees,
if I'm not wrong.
Going back and forth,
where the politicians
say, "We're willing,"
again, you go into the politicians,
"We're willing to work
on these five issues."
And then taking those five,
asking the public of these five
"what's the most important"
then maybe going back
to the experts, right?
So there's a...
Oh, I'm supposed to be short,
so I'll stop there.
But I think designing
a democratic mechanism
to arrive at that,
and doing engagement with that
rather than there just being some topic
that comes like a UFO,
like the immediate thing
if there's not a good messenger is like,
who chose this topic, right, I think.
- And so, regretfully, we are out of time,
but thankfully, this panel
and the entire conference
today has been recorded.
And you can find information
about the conference,
contact details for the presenters,
and the video clips on
the Yale ISPS website
under the Democratic Innovations Program.
I'd like to take this opportunity
to, again, thank Yale ISPS,
Alan Gerber, Pam, and Kira
for helping us organize this conference,
and thank you so much to our panelists
and all participants. Yeah.
- Thank you, Ali.
(everyone clapping)
(gentle music)